I realized that year he didn't have any
of his own cows and he had lost his
government job and they were on the
verge of not being able to be nomads
anymore so I bought him a cow
they'd been so good to me so I bought
him a cow and when I went back the next
year his uncle took me aside and said
that cow has made it possible for Perot
G to become and his family to stay
nomadic and wow talk about a profound
moment for me and I realized you know
that one cow was $200 it was it was a
lot of money for me at the time but it
didn't change my life it did change his
so that's what started the foundation
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on very excited
to be in the beautiful Ojai California
we are at the nomadic gallery we are
going to be speaking with Leslie Clark
hello hello thank you so much for coming
on the show Leslie really appreciate it
it's my pleasure
and I couldn't help but ask Leslie to
come on the show while we were visiting
this beautiful area her gallery here is
beautiful her story's beautiful I'm very
excited to be unpacking it sharing it
with you guys for those who don't know
Leslie's background she is an artisanal
gallery owner in Ojai California has
travel Tunisia 50 times
setting up general health education and
economic support to indigenous nomadic
people and you can find the links in the
bio to nomad gal comm as well as a nomad
foundation org okay Leslie let's start
things off by asking you who are you and
what do you stand for well I am
sometimes I forget this but I'm first an
artist and that is my what drives me and
that's what drove me to Africa the first
time
and that when I first started when I got
my art education a master's in in fine
arts I started traveling at the same
time and I found that I absolutely loved
to travel and so I I went to the south
of France to study to work on my masters
and I was painting on plein air all
around the Cote d'Azur and I was
somebody saw the paintings i was doing
and they asked me to do a show in
Montecarlo and so I said sure it was my
first show I was really excited about it
and I sold a bunch of paintings and I
thought wow what a good gig travel sell
paint what I see and then try and figure
out a way to sell the paintings so that
I can earn enough money for the next
trip and so that became the pattern for
my painting life how did you hooked into
painting when you were younger well it
was always something that I knew I
needed to do I never had any my high
school didn't have art education my
grammar school didn't really but my
grandfather was a painter and artist a
carpenter and he would get out his
little blackboard that was about this
big and say okay draw circles draw
triangles draw straight lines and I
would do all these things and I was
about five six at the time and I would
do all these things and my reward for
doing them correctly was that he would
draw me a horse and it was such a treat
to have him draw me a horse so I I just
from then I knew I had to draw so I just
kept drawing and I never went into a
formal education and when I went to
college I thought well I'm going to be
an artist and at the time there were no
art schools that had life drawing
classes it was all abstract
so I didn't know what to do I thought I
don't really want to I want to learn you
know anatomy and how to paint from the
old masters and all that and nobody was
teaching that at the time so I kind of
got you know distracted and went off and
did some other things for a few years
and then my parents died and I and at
the same time I got a divorce and at the
same time my ranch burned down and so it
was like this just ground zero nothing
left of my formal life so I I said I am
going to be an artist now so I went back
to school and got my degree I ended up
halfway through that degree meeting the
man that would become my future husband
and I moved to the East Coast because I
thought hey I can get a great I can get
a great education here found the best
program I could have found it was based
on on methods and materials of the
Masters and I lived in Washington DC and
I got to go to all the fabulous museums
and when there was nobody there and
learn about the and paint from the old
masters and we had a course that just
totally transformed and made my painting
life and that was called methods and
materials and from that course we were
required to paint using the materials
and the methods of every major trend in
art throughout history so I would start
with the Byzantine altar pieces and
that's what really struck me I today my
painting reflects a lot of goldleaf a
lot of sculptural elements that are
carved into gesso and this is what the
Byzantine altar pieces were or
illuminated manuscripts with gold leaf
and very
borders and all of those things continue
to inform my work my work doesn't isn't
religious and it's not the same subject
matter now it may be floral or it may be
a camel in Africa but it's got those
elements of the Byzantine and and I went
all the way through and painted in egg
oil tempera and painted in in techniques
that the Masters used and one of my one
of my projects was to paint a portrait i
portraits have always been what I was
really people is what I've always been
interested in and so I painted a
portrait of a friend in all of my
favorite artists style I did John Singer
Sargent and I did a guy and I did Klimt
and I did Raphael and I did in those in
their styles it was so much fun so
portraits ended up being in all these
different styles this it was methods and
methods and materials and it just made
me learn how to we would grind our own
pigment we would it it made me learn how
to use anything and it made me
conversant in those materials so so
whether no matter what I chose to paint
in whether it was pastels or - or
tempera or casein or now I paint in
acrylics and oils and a lot of
watercolors when I travel but I I'm
comfortable with it all and that gave me
that ability that wonderful class that
seems like something that every aspiring
artist should endeavor into that's
absolute art yeah and the wonderful
thing they did is even art history
majors had to take that class so
historians and critics would be
conversant in what these artists go
through and it's it was it was a very
transformational and wonderful moment in
my early painting life and then how did
you decide to make the the trip you see
where
see and then how did you decide to go to
the the west coast of Africa and start
painting portraits of indigenous how did
that happen
well I it was kind of a process I was
painting in in the Mediterranean area
for years I was doing this pattern of
travelling to paint and and then you
know having some kind of show so I could
earn enough money and figure out where
the next trip was going to be and I did
that for many years and then I my
husband and I decided to move back to my
home of Ojai which I was born here and
it was where I lived a lot of my life
even though my father traveled around a
bit but we moved back here and we're
thinking that we might sell my house
that I had built when I was in my early
20s and that was a whole other side of
my life I'm kind of a an architect in
many I've built six houses now cool
anyway but I just love being creative
I have design so where was I I was
talking trying to get to Africa
it's crazy like you just described also
that you you know not only do you have
your hands in things like design in
architecture as well that helps with
artistic edge but also I just want to
mention I didn't actually know that you
actually went to Mediterranean also
beforehand a couple to visit many times
and you were doing this process of going
there painting portraits and then
selling those to fund your next exactly
it's such a cool process it what it's
not exactly portraits it's people doing
what they do so in the Mediterranean it
would be sitting in cafes or at the
beach or fishing or doing what they do
so a lot of times I'll focus on a face
because I love to paint people's faces
and try
and capture the personalities but a lot
of times it'll be somebody as in Africa
you know riding on a camel or drawing
water from a well or embroidering doing
the things braiding somebody's hair and
and the process of that is I have to
paint I paint rather large paintings and
when you travel you can't lug around a
48 by 72 canvas yeah so you have to
figure out what is going to be possible
and for me it was watercolor I painted
small watercolors and journals so I'd
write about what I was seeing and
feeling and and sketch it so I got very
adept at watching people who are moving
around and capturing what they were
doing because the most posing is you
know somebody's sitting still but that's
not necessarily communicating who that
person is so their activity and their
body language and the way and what
they're interested in doing communicates
more for me and so that I would go to a
port in Greece and watch the fisherman
and this guy will be over there and he's
working on his nets and and I'll look at
him and I kind of take a mental
photograph and then I sketch it I won't
look at him again until I finish that
sketch because it will confuse me yes
because he's moved so that's my
technique of capturing some kind of
activity in a quick sketch now the
sketch might be terrible but if I look
at what I've done I remember it I can
smell it I can feel the temperature it
is all captured in those silly ugly
lines that I've drawn in my journal but
I have to do that in order to get to the
pain
yes yes okay so there's a mental of a
snapshot of a in in in action us a human
on the plane that's in action with the
process that they're in that they're
doing that they may be in love with
doing and that then that that first of
all is much different than like you're
describing a portrait of just positioned
it catches it catches them in their
essence of what they do and then also
like you said Casey capture this
mentally as a photograph and then you
bring it into your sketchbook and you
don't look back you just you sketch that
out and then you from there you decide
whether or not you want to take that to
canvas and usually I mean if it's in a
quick in my journal I may take it to a
small or a little bit larger watercolor
that's somewhat more detailed first but
I'll never take it to canvas while I'm
traveling that happens once I get back
into my studio so I will do maybe
several sketches a couple of small
watercolors of a subject matter or maybe
one just depending on the time because
people aren't going to stand around and
keep doing what they're doing so that I
can draw them but there's always
something that and I sometimes don't
know whether it's going to be a big
painting until I get back and I kind of
get into what I what I've done sometimes
I know immediately this is going to be
the painting from this trip
the major painting sometimes cool and
and then can you so then so sometimes
you had watercolor and then you bring
them back and you pick out of the ones
that you've sketched in your notebook
which ones in your studio in Ojai that
you want to turn em onto canvas and then
you share that moment that you captured
across the planet with other people that
come to your gallery and decide to bring
that into the
home at those moments and kind of bring
the world closer together through that
process exactly this beautiful and
thence how many would you say that you
out of the the total if you go on a trip
for is it a couple weeks how many
examples of sketches would you make and
then how many of those would return to
canvas I would when I was you know on a
trip of maybe I'd usually go for three
weeks or so and I'd probably do Oh
fifty sketches in my journal probably
forty larger watercolors and then I come
back and maybe do ten to fifteen larger
pieces so neat and then would you let
the the people come into the gallery
know that you by by supporting this
artwork you were funding my next travels
and so yeah how did the transition then
happen how many times you go to the
Mediterranean and how did it come up to
go to West Africa well I moved back from
my education was in Washington DC I
moved back to Ojai built a home or moved
back into a home I'd already built but I
met my now husband and he moved back
here and we at first I thought we'd
probably moved back to the East Coast
because he's an East Coast person and I
thought oh he's not going to adapt to
this cuz he is a horseman and that's his
passion we get along very well because
he lets me be Who I am and I let him be
who he is and sometimes we'll be apart
from each other for six months of the
year but it's because we understand that
each other has something that is really
who they are and important so we Moomba
who moved out here to Ojai to sell the
house that I'd built
before and he totally fell in love with
oh hi totally fell in love with being a
horseman cowboy instead of Polo playing
fox hunting steeplechasing East Coast
guy on a horse and and totally adapted
he he couldn't possibly leave Ojai now
he's more Ojai than I am anyway so we
decided to we had put the house on the
market found a good buyer and we decided
to build another house to sell that one
and build another one that was more
oriented toward my having me having a
studio and a place to display paintings
and so for a while I started traveling
closer by when I moved to California
getting to the Mediterranean was a
schlep it was a long way and also if I
was building a house I didn't want to go
too far and so I started traveling in
Central America well I had a show of a
series I've done from Guatemala and a
woman came up and said you know I love
this painting would you have any
interest in painting in trading for a
trip a river rafting trip between on the
river that was some Ascenta which is
between Chiapas and Guatemala and and
it's basically to visit the Mayan ruins
and I was of course and so I we agreed
on that I took the trip and entering the
Mayan ruins from the river is the way to
do it because that's the way they were
built all of these phenomenal
plants and temples that have these
beautiful carvings if they are facing
the rivers the little airports that
there you come in the back door if you
arrive in the jungle in an airport and
can come through in a jeep but entering
it seeing it by River is just
spectacular because they are built to
impress and from the river so did the
river trip painted a this is a long
story but we'll eventually get to Africa
I saw a man in this jungle
Viney temple that was a ruin and there
was a guy with this long black hair and
a white tunic and he just kind of led it
through anything disappeared and then I
saw him again and I asked my guide who
is this guy and he said oh that's a lock
and Dawn they they are they live here
and this temple is their sacred site but
they're not really allowed to be here
because the government reserves it for
tourists and I'm like what well it's
obvious he was using it anyway he was
there and so I did a painting of this
guy I did a really quick sketch and I
did a painting and I was invited back
the next year to Palenque to a group of
my inist s-- who were at the time
deciphering the Mayan glyphs kind of you
know like the rosetta stone and there
and they were doing it through the
connection with the lock and Onis
because the lock and don had never been
affected by the Spanish conquest they
were in the jungle not wealthy small
tribe so they were speaking the same
language so they understood what though
they provided the link that helped these
people translate anyway that's a
digression I go to I take this huge
painting I'd done of this lock and done
man and I'm exhibiting it in this this
Hall along with other paintings I've
done of the Mayan ruins and this man
walks in to the and he's got long black
hair and a white tunic and he walks up
to the painting and he says that's my
brother yeah so I
met him he was to be the next chief here
he is in totally out of his element he's
this rainforest guy and he's in with all
these Western you know European and
American scientists and and he's just
cruising along comfortable it doesn't
speak any language that you know so
anyway I I was so fascinated by him that
I asked my guide to to see if he would
let me follow him around in the
rainforest for a couple of days so I
could paint him yes and he did and so I
spent a few days just you know creeping
around I felt like an elephant in the
rainforest is he just going through
kissers there's all of these you know
vines everywhere and anyway so I I did
that and it was and it ain't a whole
series of this guy and was set to go
back to this same convention the next
year and there was an uprising the
Zapatista uprising and I couldn't go
back how was the South youth uprising
yes so I I had this time set aside I had
money saved and I thought you know where
am I going to find indigenous people
that have I want more of this I want to
be to figure out why the he was so
comfortable with who he was not totally
out of his element why wasn't he scared
why wasn't he nervous he was just I am
Who I am and I and then as I was so
comfortable with him on our days in the
rainforest I wanted more of that
so I decided Africa was the deal and
that's what led me there
and I had seen a book by Carol Beckwith
called nomads of knee chair and I wanted
to meet those people they were but the
what kind of part of it was a spiritual
thing that I had felt that I had had
with him but it was also I want to just
exotic subject matter to paint well I
finally got to New Year and and met I'd
found a woman who had been there before
and we went together and the first Nomad
I ever met there was a big rebellion
going on I couldn't get into the north
to meet the Tuareg nomads but I could
meet the wa da b which is the group that
carol Beckwith's book was about nomads
of new Jerr and they have this beauty
contest where the men compete and the
women judge and they it's the men in
their culture the men can't propose to a
woman it's a marriage festival but the
guys can't propose they have to make
themselves so irresistible that the
woman proposed to them and that's what
this beauty contest is all about and but
I didn't know I was trying to find this
contest because I'd seen it in the book
and it took a couple years because there
was a rebellion going on and we couldn't
get north they were they were shooting
at us and there at the military that
were blocking us that we didn't actually
get shot at that trip but it was it was
a process and when I finally did to get
to them I transformed my life I became I
from 93 on I've been back to New Year
for every year at least twice sometimes
three times and for as much as six
months in the year whoa okay so let's um
let's briefly mentioned the visit to the
Mayan ruins through the river and what
was the indigenous that was there in the
black and white whoa
the name of the lock on dawn lock on
doing mm-hmm okay and then you and then
when you went to the the Mayan the
congregation I was happening with some
of the experts that we were looking at
the glyphs that that someone said that
it's my brother there and then that's so
neat how that happened then you went
into the rain forest for three days
following the lock undone chip to be
chief mmm hi um was this man Caillou
whoa see that right there in itself is
such a profoundly life-changing
experience following Caillou him for
three days in the in in the rain forest
and watching how Caillou moves and
treats that like a native thing and were
kind of like to follow and be all like
awkward and yeah the thing that was
really striking is I would always ask
about the plants there were so many
plants I mean it's a jungle this is a
rain forest and I would say well so
what's that
and they'd say Sylvestre so I finally
and everything was Sylvester it turns
out that that meant wild okay so if they
don't name their plants but they can
tell you what everything is used for
okay so when you ask about a plant they
won't have a name for it they will oh
that's the plant that cures headaches
that's the plant that's good for your
stomach but that's the plant that you
rub on a wound and that's how they would
always describe so they move visually by
the specific healing process that the
plant helps with now we're so lost here
in the United States we know all of our
logos and but we don't can't name a
couple different plants or trees or
flowers okay and I can see how this like
hooked you into wanting to go I'm okay
in the book was on nomads of new share
was the book okay and then it's the wood
Buddha whoa doggy Dobby
ooh Dobby and
first of all nomadic is that's that that
that in itself is much different than a
lot of other indigenous have a home that
they have to live in and so no maddox
different than that but then also like
you said there's these cultural
processes of indigenous Heritage's that
I think are so beautiful like these so
they're suspend rests up and have a
competition for the women to propose to
things like that are completely
different and so it's very unique and
it's cool to be process of that so the
first trip was 93 at least two to three
times a year since that and tell us
about yeah these first times that you
started going out there and then and
then we'll get into more on the general
health clinics side of things okay so I
met this nomad his name was per oggi and
he had a large family most nomads do
they move with you know the note that
would ah be can have four wives and per
oggi was so handsome and so charming
that he had more than his allotted for
but they'd he once I asked him down the
road after I got to know him pretty well
and I learned their language and all
this I asked him how many wives
he'd had and he said well I think maybe
32 but only eight stayed more than two
weeks anyway I the first family that I
met on that first trip became my my
family for years and I traveled back to
see them I would arrange because they
don't have a house the second time I
didn't the the first time I met them
they were just so lovely and they were
that we couldn't get into the North
where those dances that I was just dying
to see were so the kids all the young
men and women who were of that
that would be in those competitions were
BIA behind the rebel lines so we
couldn't go there and I was just
devastated but the kids who were like
between 8 and 12 years old weren't quite
old enough to be in the competitions
they did all the dances for us and they
made up for us and they and they would
go out and all night long they'd be
singing and they were so excited because
we were there and they would do this
kind of their version it was so
wonderful I thought you know this is
what childhood should be I always felt
sad that the people that my I mean in my
childhood I could ride my bike anywhere
I can my parents would let me you know
walk down the street by myself it's kind
of not the case anymore and I felt so
sad for kids of our world today they've
got everything they've got food and and
shelter and wealth and comforts that
they don't have freedom mmm and these
kids as long as they got up in the
morning to do their chores and they knew
they had to when you're up until about
five years old you can do anything you
want and you're just adored and
everybody coddles you and that's but
five on you have chores and but they
could stay up all night if they wanted
to as long as they got up and did their
chores so they would have and the big
brothers would you know protect them
from the snake that might bite them or I
mean it was such a free you know
fabulous life for a child and I got a
little taste of what the festivals were
going to be like as they would sing that
the the songs and and recreate these for
us and I was so pleased with the visit
and we the
head of the family for og took us around
to visit other families and there were
some little celebrations not the big the
big deal which I got to the next year
but when it came time to leave I didn't
realize how poor they actually were they
didn't have any cows they had just been
through a major drought in West Africa
the eighties decimated all the herds in
West Africa and this family were trying
to hang on to being nomads but he had
just gotten kind of a job out of his
regular territory that's why I was able
even to meet him because normally the
nomads would all have been farther north
and he was planting trees for the
government and this was a not kind of a
normal thing for him but he didn't have
anything else and he had no animals and
but they would do they would do anything
for us he came along and took me to
other friends so I could meet other
other wood obby and so when I left I
organized a way for to communicate with
him and he said well he doesn't know how
to write but he has somebody in the town
where we could maybe the nearby nearest
town which is like a four-hour drive
away a week by there you know are
several days by donkey but we took him
into the town showed him the post office
how to mail a letter he introduced me to
the person that could write a letter for
him this is such a complicated means of
communication there were no cell phones
or anything like that in the day so I I
came back thinking am I ever gonna get
back to see this you know it just it was
so deep in my heart and of course I came
back and started painting I did so many
paintings of per oggi I did paintings of
all of his kids and his wives and and
the herds and it was just every time I
was doing a painting I was there and so
I knew I had to get back
didn't have a clue how to find him but I
kept trying I kept trying to communicate
by letter I never got a letter back but
I was writing and saying okay I'm going
to be here on a search in such-and-such
a day can you meet me and leap of faith
so I get back the next year I go to the
house of the person that was supposed to
write the letters and per oggi had never
gotten any of them so he didn't know I
was coming back so we start cruising
around in the bush looking for a nomad
and and the guide kind of knew what
their I mean he he's the one that took
me the first time so he knew what their
housing looks like they call them moral
which is house but it's a arced root
thing with mats on it and so he kind of
knew what a what Dobby camp would look
like and we we went around and went
around for a couple of days asking and
nobody had heard of per oggi and so
we're driving down and there's a guy
walking down the road and we stop and
ask us in there's nobody around so
anytime you see anybody you ask them
what you need to know so yeah yes this
guy and he said oh yeah I know per oggi
is my cousin so he said and yeah he's at
a big festival and I'll take you I I got
there we we went through another several
hours of driving through the bush and
the problem for nomads is they don't
have cars so they'll say oh well just
it's just over here but the car can't
get over that big gully or can't so you
really are you're gonna take a whole
different route than they would be able
to normally you know because they can
walk and they will and their camel can
go places where the car can't go or
their donkey can so anyway we eventually
get to this place
and I see all of these guys in a line
and there's these tall feathers and
there's a lot of dust and there's herds
milling around and I hear some chanting
and then I look over and here comes per
oggi and he's clappy and he is so
excited yeah so it's like how could this
have happened
yeah well needless to say over the years
getting to find the nomads that you want
to find has always been a challenge I
can be developed a means of
communication with a guy who had it in
those days that you had to go to a
telecenter to make a phone call so there
was a guy at this place he would help
per oggi make a phone call to me and
that way I could find out we could
arrange where I would meet him on at a
roadside somewhere well one time I went
back to meet him and we went to find his
family and he couldn't find him he's the
head of the house he's with nomads he's
the head of the household and he can't
find his own family so think how hard it
is for us he's looking for a couple days
yeah we asked everybody nobody's seen
him but when he leaves his wives or his
oldest son or whoever makes the decision
so often it's the woman they've got to
go where there's pasture because the
herds aren't gonna survive if so in
those days I thought it was these were
his cows they weren't it was an extended
family group and they helped each other
out so his his uncle was letting
perogies family kind of live off of the
milk from his cows I realized that year
he didn't have any of his own cows and
he had lost his government job and they
were on the verge of not being able to
be nomads anymore
so I bought him a cow they'd been so
good to me so I bought him a cow and
when I went back then
shir his uncle took me aside and said
that cow has made it possible for no /
OG to become and his family to stay
nomadic and wow talk about a profound
moment for me and I realized you know
that one cow was $200 it was it was a
lot of money for me at the time but it
didn't change my life it did change his
so that's what started the foundation
and I knew I had to start asking people
for help because I couldn't buy too many
cows and I didn't but I knew that my
link between them and here and people
with money and willingness to be
generous would could make a difference
to their lives okay it's yeah how does
one even find if the if the if Perot you
can't find it takes several days divided
this nomadic family a good luck you
going and trying yourself and you did
and you made this tie and I think it's
so beautiful that if there's a way to
find people around the world that lives
can be changed so that their original
traditions can be upheld through the
generous contributions of people from
around the world they get like you or
were the link the the middle connect
armies between the two and so okay so
then so the the animal the cow acts as a
source of food for them through the milk
and then also as they have to take it to
pasture and that's what keeps the nomads
and moving so that cow can continue
eating something okay
okay and then and then you see your also
nomadic when you're there for several I
I was determined to when I first went
and met the family I was with a guide
who was from another ethnic group nomads
are not considered to be none of them
are educated at the time they weren't
and they're kind of considered by the
educated people the people that can
drive cars and happy guides in the
agencies as barbarians so he interpreted
things between myself and pierogies
family that were coloring what how he
wanted me to believe these people were
they weren't what they were actually
saying so I started right away I didn't
know this then I found it out after I
learned the language so I started and
they were so wonderful at helping me
learn the language there no there were
no dictionaries I just made my own
dictionary and I'd pointed things and
they tell me this and and and they were
they were so helpful that I would okay
four full days this weird language that
has all these noun classes and if you
want to describe a beautiful flower the
word for beautiful is different than if
you're seeing a beautiful house or
beautiful land because it's a different
noun class so the word beautiful isn't
beautiful every time it's a whole
different word depending on what its
modifying so that really confused me and
so I just used the same word no matter
what damn class it was and so they would
repeat my mistakes
so I would understand what they were
saying I've avenged enough so I knew
they were they were not speaking correct
fulfill today but they were doing it so
I would understand and they were trying
to help me it was it was so so charming
and delightful on their part but I
decided I wanted to be on my own and I
wanted to learn what it was like to
migrate so I arranged the one thing I
needed to have was a good water and so I
had a car dropped me off with you know
five five gallon jerry cans of water
that we could carry on our camels and
other than that I just had a mattress
and I didn't have a tent I just had a
mattress and a mosquito net and when I'd
ride on the camel every day and we
stopped in a new place and the thing
that you if you find a really good place
is one that has shade because we're in
the Sahara Desert so it's gonna be at
least a hundred degrees every day in
April it's 140 I didn't go again in
April I went only once I didn't want to
do 140 thing again but I was when I was
we were migrating it was sometimes there
wouldn't be shade so they would they're
there there's a plant it's kind of it's
a kind of milkweed they would arrive at
a spot and within ten minutes they had
harvested these little these little
sticks with leaves and made a shade
shelter called the room furrow and we
would stop and we'd be able to have
shade because you really can't not have
shade in that part of the world so and
the thorn trees don't forgot provide
great shade but the wood Dobby pinned
their blankets under under the tree so
that it's dense shade instead of just
little thorny yes yes well yeah yeah the
the skills that can be gained from from
spending time with indigenous people
like that that's so interesting and then
so then what was it like then as you are
visiting you know several times a year
you're spending months at a time with
them you're learning more their language
you're making your own dictionary this
type of neat things then when did it
kind of come up that
that you could potentially not only help
you a link with with support to preserve
their their culture but also some of the
general health things that were coming
up yeah well it really the wouldhave
were very they're the only they're a
part of a large ethnic group the Fulani
but they have kind of split off and
they're the only truly nomadic so and
they're pretty isolated and almost none
are educated so the key to doing taking
more steps was to meet the Tuareg the
Tuareg is another nomadic group the wa
da b are more in the south they have
cattle and and and she mostly and
there's more pasture land the Tuareg are
desert people and they're desert
warriors and they have camels and goats
because that those animals live can live
in the more arid north where where it's
a lot of sand and not as much pasture
land but and I had wanted to meet them
the first trip but I couldn't go because
of this rebellion well the next trip we
were allowed to go and I went but we had
to go in a convoy that was that was
guarded that was led by armed vehicles
so we went up into the north to Agra des
and the woman that I was with had known
this man who had been it started the
main tourist agency in the area he was a
Tuareg and he was the rebel leader so
the rebellion was still going on and she
found a way to meet him
we'd travel up into the into this very
remote area and we look over and here
comes this this convoy of vehicles with
50 calibers on their roofs and and all
these you know turbine guys and we're
all I and I'm going like this and it's
him it's mano Dayak and he was the most
charming cosmopolitan guy and he sat
down at our table and told us his story
and he said and I was with this kind of
semi tourist group and my friend Irma at
the time and we were going to just stay
a day and then go back but and I had
some extra time and he invited me to go
along and meet his rebels and travel
through the desert nobody else was able
to go there at the time because they
controlled the desert and there would be
battles so I said he was a very charming
and very competent guy so I he said well
you have to help God there I've got so
many stories to tell I'm gonna love this
these are such good stories so he said
well come back and meet be in Agadez on
such-and-such a day but don't stay in
August because it will be suspicious if
you wait around they might think you're
trying to help me and so the people that
were the foreigners that were there at
the moment the government thought might
because the Tuareg were very connected
to the French and to white people in
general this especially through mono
died
who has gotten his education in France
and America and he was trying to
negotiate the peace through the white
people the French and the Americans but
the government did not like that at all
and so they had this blockade on anybody
leaving town that that could be
providing them with gas or supplies or
whatever so he said don't stay in August
just wait and just do something and then
come back and meet me on such and such a
day and I will send a driver in and he
will take it take you out and that way
you can meet us yeah so what am I going
to do
where do I go so I got a guide who was
going to take me by camel to a wedding
that was about a day and a half trip to
out of August so I he was recommended by
somebody so I thought well this is
probably okay I've never been on a camel
before it's holy we go out and we're
traveling along and and and it's you
know it's about four or five hours on
the camel and it's just you know this
kind of rub lee wadi it's a dry riverbed
kind of thing that we're going through
and and he said do you want to stop and
have lunch and and take a break and i'm
going yeah so we stopped and I didn't
know I mean there was no this is the
middle of nowhere I am in the middle of
nowhere and he says just excuse me a
minute I have to go behind the bush but
if my camp my camel isn't as
well-trained as yours so if he jumps up
grab his rope don't let him run away and
I said okay and so he goes behind the
bush
of course the camel jumps up I grab the
rope and the camel pulls and there and
the Rope is attached by a ring in their
nose
he pulls loose and goes running off and
Here I am holding the rope while I grab
my camel who's very well behaved and
he's staying there and
and I go suppose a common choice the
camel he's disappearing he goes running
after the camel and realizes very soon
that the camel is going to outrun him
yeah so he comes back and grabs my camel
and you're stuck waiting there ah so
what do I have
he has my food my water my I have a mat
and I have my sketchbook yes oh I'm
sitting there under a thorn tree and you
know writing in my journal and sketching
and waiting for Musa to come back an
hour goes by two hours goes by and I'm
going all right I'm going through all
these things how what how am I gonna get
out of here I can't really start walking
now because it's so hot and I have no
water I will die
how long does somebody take to die yeah
yeah and I'm going through office thank
you these metal things
and then I or what should I wait to tell
it's dark well I won't be able to see
the tracks when it's dark going through
those so have I just stepped into the
thing that's gonna finally you know be a
the end and then this little creaky old
man comes walking up and he's you know
toothless and he's got no shoes on and
he just comes over and his turban didn't
robed he comes over and and nods at man
sits down next to me
and I'm thinking well if he's here he
knows where other people are yeah he
knows I'm a white person I don't survive
well out here he will know how to help
me I couldn't talk to him but I knew he
was my guardian angel I knew I was safe
it took me it took Musa four hours to
get back it was almost dark but by the
time he got back
he got back to that yeah so they must
have taken him like two hours one
direction yeah get the camel yep he got
the camel had gotten all the way back to
Augie des running and so so I'd lived to
tell the tale and we went on to the and
I asked moose about the guy and he said
well he lives around here I don't know
who he is but I always thought it's
better that made me know that I would
say I was okay yeah ya know as you were
running all of the possibility okay and
then then you went to the wedding and
then and the wedding was really
phenomenal and then I got back into
Agadez this guy comes to meet me and
says okay you know come on we're going
to drive her home and he drives a couple
hours and then somebody else comes to
meet me he drops me off in this little
spot and somebody else comes to meet me
there takes me out and eventually I get
out to Mono and the rebels and I'm there
with all of these I mean and I am so
naive at this moment right now I'm kind
of I'm kind of used to traveling with
armed folks but not in those days I'm
just kind of wide-eyed but mano was so
competent and and charming and I could
hardly speak French even you know so I
couldn't even talk to these people
hardly but he wanted people to
understand what they were fighting for
he's we weren't this isn't some stupid
armed insurgency we're fighting for the
survival of our culture and he told me
the whole story of why they were doing
it and and he was such a brilliant guy
the the people it's they were they're
illiterate they don't have telephones
and radio you know and radios and
televisions and all that so he devised a
way of communication music was really
important he brought in guitars the guys
the whole generation of rebels learn all
many of them
and how to play the guitar and they
wrote songs that explained where to go
what you know what that they were
fighting for their survival of their
culture this is and if you're going to
join us come to this spot and it was all
kind of in code but everybody understood
it and they sent it from Camp to camp in
cassette tapes in boom boxes and that's
how they communicate eventually the
government banned the music made it way
more popular because they banned it but
it the entire generation of musicians of
young men knew how to play and sing the
all of these songs and the songs became
just legendary and I became I got
eventually I connected to many of the
musicians and I brought him over to Ojai
and the first group was one guy was a
nephew of mono Dayak and and his cousin
came with him on the second trip and
they eventually just split up and didn't
didn't play in the same group anymore
but the cousin was just back here and I
brought them together four times they
helped raise money for the foundation
which we haven't even gotten to the
foundations much yet but he came back
this year being the first musician from
knee chair to ever be nominated for a
Grammy whoa-oh
so proud of that kid yes he's a
world-famous guy but getting back to
mono in a drowsy communication story to
the guitar is yes the way to communicate
and cassettes and boombox and and it was
a huge importance and everybody knew I
mean to this day they know all the rebel
songs and this was in 95 so I traveled
with mono for three weeks and we visited
the camps of the people who were who
were his rebels and
and these were they were nomadic
families and those nomads were helping
these rebels survive because they didn't
have anything to eat I mean I all of the
young men that I that I met in those
days and they eventually came here and
they would starve to death in the Hills
because they didn't have and as a result
they decimated the population the
wildlife the gazelles the ostrich and
the military who were out there fighting
them were doing the same thing so it was
really hard on the wildlife and it was
really hard on them too
and the women were fighting the good
fight trying to get them you know food
and gas and all of that but they were
just trying to be able to have some kind
of rights in their own territory and
they never they'd never had anybody in
the political spectrum because they
weren't educated they weren't enough of
them that were educated that's all
changed now and fact the guy who runs
our foundation now is a Tuareg man who
was educated and is and they very very
consciously decided to integrate
themselves into the political system so
that they would have some kind of kind
of control
well okay okay so yes so lead us into
they're still obviously so much to talk
about there's some for another
conversation although getting to more of
the political nuance and cultural
preservation and all this type of stuff
so then yes so then how did it how did
it end up the realization that by you
know by providing more general health
opportunities as well as economic
opportunities it could help the key as I
said was that's why I went into the
story about the torrent the key was the
Tuareg because they had the the
knowledge of the territory and and more
of them had education and
the I ended up meeting the youngest
rebel leader from that rebellion
brilliant guy who to this day I met him
in 2005 he is still our representative
and he and I working together have
devised ways that are are realistic and
practical I was winging it with the
foundation initially and we did start
the first school that the wa dhabi had
ever had and because they had told me
they wanted it but i but it was and and
it's still it's still running today but
i didn't really have a plan I was just
doing little things that you know people
seem to need I'd buy cows for people and
that kind of thing what got me into the
realm of having a plan and a system was
meeting CD McMunn whose are this rebel
leader who is just a brilliant man and
that led us into as I told you the story
of trying to find a nomad when you've
got the head of household in your car
it's not an easy thing and that's why
nobody helps them that's why no no
humanitarian organizations work out
there because if there's no bang for the
buck it's too hard to drive around and
spend a whole bunch of money and
vaccinate 14 people you know it's just
not practical so they want to have the
good statistics meanwhile these people
are left out in the cold so what we
decided to do was there the mobile ones
let them come to us
and there's one migration route there's
an area that's known for the it's called
The Cure cell a it's a salt cure it's
half we're all animals the pasture is
very rich and salty and animals have to
have salt and so they all come to this
one area and they
by this one area and all the nomads in
the whole country try to get to this
area because that's where their animals
are going to get really healthy to make
it through the long dry season and so we
were given a well on this migration
route and decided hey because we were
given the well it gave us the right to
build something there you're never going
to get a nomad to go into the city
because they believe that you go into a
city and die because when they have
serious health problems they wait so
long until they're so desperate that
they do go into the city and it's too
late to care for them so they die hmm
and so it's this catch-22 you don't go
into the city because you're gonna die
there well so we decided we're gonna
build these things in their comfort zone
on their migration route we built a
medical clinic and the first at the
opening of the clinic in 2009 we treated
over a thousand patients in a week none
of them had seen a none of them had ever
seen a doctor they were just desperate
now a lot of it was not really useful
work because because in the culture the
elders are respected the elders got to
come in first and they're going all over
like some pain so they have arthritis or
cataracts or things that we couldn't
really do anything about except give an
aspirin and they think that aspirin is
miraculous so but we did get to the
point where we were treating some real
things and we hired a local person to
start treating them well over the years
we stopped having to do medical mesh
missions where our doctors were treating
the patients because they had care all
the time there's the stat the clinic is
staffed and so they don't have these
health this desperation but we did find
that the
the one group that was really at risk is
pregnant women because they're not gonna
get on a donkey to come to our clinic
when they go into labor so
coincidentally I meet this obstetrician
in Ojai whose retiree it was retired and
his life is about service and so he
really wanted to get involved in this
program he invented he devised a midwife
training program we selected women they
hadn't really had any any experience
particularly but they were competent
women who are respected and their
communities selected them and what you
have is a woman from an extended family
group that will move with that family
group and she would come in to our
training center next to our clinic and
learn what to do and the big deal was
prenatal care but what we discovered
after that the first two training
sessions was and I lost five friends in
childbirth they were not their first
children it was the maternal these women
died left orphans and we couldn't figure
out what this what is this it was the
country has a very high maternal
mortality rate but they're not really
any statistics for nomads so we didn't
really know but I knew personally I lost
five friends so when we started this
program we realized that what was
killing him was dehydration they as a
culture don't drink water because they
live in the Sahara Desert and in order
to protect your community and be
cooperative and not be greedy you limit
your water and that's a cultural
stricture and when we got the community
behind it and they they want to protect
their pregnant women
we've pretty much cut out maternal
mortality with there were a lot of other
things but that was the biggie and such
a surprise yes the when you were telling
me this yesterday it was so beautiful
learning about it from you first of all
it's crazy
interesting that you had to set up the
general health clinic on the migration
route and near this is dassault pasture
which is where you knew that there would
be the nomads migrating through and that
they would stop and get general health
needs taken care of
that's brilliant that that's like that's
a way to make it to make general health
advancements set it up right there at a
key point on the migration route and
then also that I remember when you were
teaching me about this I had this you
know this overwhelming feeling of like
beauty that that it's it's it's so
beautiful that there's so much
selflessness that happens with with
water restriction because you want the
to to to provide for others and that at
the same time that having a little bit
more abundance of water prevents that
dehydration which prevents the maternal
mortality so again another one of those
like wow moments that that hydration can
save lives and so then so then how did
that end up end up progressing because
you you were teaching me that there's
you're you're teaching one of the
members of the of the indigenous tribe
to then be trained in midwifery skills
to assist with the birth process for
other tribe members well we have
programs where the the communities
select the women they come in to the
Thomas na Center adult education center
we started with the medical clinic which
kind of gave us everybody knew we were
there because they weren't going to go
to the city to get health care they
wanted to come to us and so that gave us
this recognition we started a boarding
school where the kids
we feed the kids we we pay the teacher
we pay this supplies the but the pair
and we build the school but the parents
have to care for the kids provide the
caregivers they stay at the school
that's the only way nomads can get an
education is to be able to live at the
school because they don't live in one
place so our training programs are a
group of what now we have 37 women
working that are trained by doctor
originally the doctor that devised the
program and now there's he retired at
age 85 from our program but he went for
six visits before that and now we have a
doctor OBGYN and her midwife sister and
they're continuing the training and
there it's all based on on reenactment
of the we have the the midwives there
five languages spoken here yeah and
these are illiterate women also so
you're not going to give him reading
material yeah you either do things by
pictures or you reenact and it can be so
much fun it's we now all of woman team
the clinic director is a woman the two
doctors are women I am in all the all
the midwives and then we get them up
there and say okay tell us what you do
on the first prenatal visit what do you
ask the patient what do you give the
patient and they have they go through
the whole process what do you do on the
second penis so we have them do three
prenatal visits and then and then the
big thing is preparing for an evacuation
if it's necessary because you know
there's some a lot of things they can't
do but they can take blood pressure so
they've learned they can't do anything
about it but they've learned how to take
it and know that this woman is at risk
of preeclampsia which is a result of
high blood pressure in pregnancy and it
can cause death and if she's got high
blood pressure in her pregnancy get her
next to a hospital when she's going to
deliver
they've they're doing it they're doing
it we haven't lost one woman in our in
over two thousand births since we
started and that we we have lost three
that died as a result of malaria but
that was after they got to the hospital
Wow a 2000 total no deaths Wow wah wah
wah wah wah
asta tist ik for the country was one in
seven my turn was what it was yeah yeah
yeah and now but the nomads have never
had statistics I just had this anecdotal
thank personal experience of losing five
oh but now we have these little reports
that the women can fill out so we know
how many women died in the or none but
it's that's part of the column that they
have to fill out they put their mark
down they side row a little picture of a
of a dead woman and a dead baby or a
woman that has fever a woman that has
what are the other things that are on
the report anyway we have statistics now
that have never been available for
nomads because they're these illiterate
women are making out their reports so
it's a very very successful program I'm
so proud of it I could burst yeah yeah
37 total yeah functioning functioning we
call them traditional birth attendants
or in new year they're called my trone's
my thrones Wow and also the fact that
they go off of memory that they store
this in their memory they're not writing
it down no notes no notes yeah just go
through the process enough times until
you've solidified it Wow and okay so
this is one of many of the so generous
so the general health clinic there's
also the foundation nomads foundations
also working on Economic Opportunity in
general as well and so you do cool
things like like like by incredible
Goods and then that have a deep cultural
meaning and then you bring them to Ojai
in this gallery and you share it with
other people and share that message then
all the other cool things that you're
teaching about the adult education
programs motorcycle repair solar panels
earth baked buildings for storehouses
cereal banks microcredits so this is a
lot of different option ality for
Economic Opportunity and so teach us
about how that's been going
well I've you find that I see a lot of
big organizations focusing on a specific
thing and if you cure malaria for
instance you end up having a lot of
people that didn't die but those people
need to eat they need to have jobs than
you'd ever occations
you can't just I feel very personally I
feel that you have to address all those
things or else you're missing the boat
and so one of the big risks in the area
has been that the young men without
opportunities and they a lot of them
were in rebellion before and so the only
skill they had is with arms are being
recruited into terrorism because they're
surrounded by Libya Algeria Mali
countries that are in Nigeria at the
countries that are very rife with
terrorism so we wanted to give them some
kind of opportunity so if they don't
have to do that because they don't
really want to do that
that's dangerous get killed it's not and
they that's not what they wanted I mean
even the rebellion using arms in the
rebellion is not what they wanted to do
they did it out of necessity just to
survive you know for the survival of
their culture so we did a lot of
programs addressing young men
microcredit was very successful
they if they have something to do at
home they won't go across the book and
they've always had the habit to go to
Libya or Algeria which are very loyal
rich countries and that's where they
could find jobs now there aren't any
jobs it's just terrorism and so they in
order to stop them from going there you
give them a $200 loan most of them did
this very brilliant thing nomads don't
live next to the grocery store they have
to go send their donkey or their camel
for a week to go and get grain or tea
and sugar which is terribly important to
them in the town the nearest town so
these guys would would take their $200
and buy a stock and get it transported
to where their families are moving and
that is that gave them they sell it at
profit it would be a big advantage to
the families because they weren't
spending all that time to get in to do
their own shopping and so it gave them
some profits in weed we recirculated
those loans for about four years and as
soon as they pay back the loan in they'd
have six months with the $200 loan they
pay it back and they'd have some little
business going and somebody else would
get the money and so they we had we've
done over 200 loans yes I mean that kept
that kept 200 young men from going into
terrorism yes we did we found that they
really liked motorcycles because they're
faster than camels and they cost about
the same as a camel and are a little bit
less than a camel problem is you got to
put gas in them
so there's something that you've got to
pay for and you got to repair them they
don't just eat past you you don't just
take care of them like they know how to
take care of camels so anyway we did
announce that we were going to do a
motorcycle repair training and we had
funding for 20 because we wanted to buy
tools for these guys that were trained
got a local guy who was a really good
mechanic that I've known for many years
and he said yeah I'll do this this is
great
but forty people showed up and 40 more
wanted it want to the training we could
only give the tools to 20 but this next
year we're gonna do it again because
already five of those guys who were in
that training are making their living
repairing other people's motorcycles and
it was two week training and they have
the tools and they can you know they're
they're cruising now so the solar panel
those project we taught them how to
build solar panels they we kind of hit a
snag and all of the projects that I've
done have been or the foundation has
done you're going to have plenty of
failures and that's how you get better
the the the big failure in solar panels
is they could build the panel's they
knew how to to solder the little
photovoltaic cells together and the only
thing we had to bring in was those
photovoltaic cells we made the frames
and had the glass and the backing and
the wiring and all of that local problem
is you can't get very strong glass there
so they made these beautiful panels we
had schools electrified we had our
Center electrified by our students we
had Gardens electrified the panel's only
last a couple years because the winds
are so strong the glass breaks so what
they were very successful that was small
charging things for cell phones but it
gave them this this knowledge of solar
so a lot of them are working for solar
companies now and or they're doing their
own little projects that our solar
related so you take what you can get
you know you some is perfect and some
and the Midwife is almost perfect but it
takes our annual revision and supplying
them with the things that they need and
you know you just hope that most of them
are successful
and then what do you see now with you
know approaching now the year 2020 and
the way that we're making advancements
with all of the exponential technologies
on around the world and we're also
trying to desperately like preserve
indigenous wisdom because we know
there's so much important understanding
of the interconnectedness of us with our
planet and the ecosystem that we live in
and how to treat it
spiritually so how do you see this inter
playing in the in the future the way
that we engage with indigenous tribes
around the world to help them with
Economic Opportunity general health but
also learn the some of the philosophy
some of the spirituality some of that
indigenous wisdom as well how do you how
do you see that interplaying
well technology has been a major thing
most most nomads have cell phones
nomads generally they're still very
there's a 70 Plus percent illiteracy in
new share and higher than that among
nomads so they're not able to you know
type out stuff on a computer but they
all have cell phones and they use
whatsapp so that's all which is vocal
and so they can and they have they do a
lot of social media stuff there they
have Facebook and they have groups that
and they're nomads are major
communicators when I before cellphones
you never let a camel go by without
stopping that camel and asking what what
the pasture was like over there or what
you know was on the road or what your
always always communicating they the
cellphone companies had no idea how much
this the nomadic population would would
subscribe to cell phones huge but it's
not a bad
you know getting them out of their
culture it's about hey have you seen my
camel yeah or what's is that a disease
oh can you get vaccinations at that but
it's about it's it's really a lot about
preserving their culture and it's easier
to communicate in that way then you know
walking down the path and running into
somebody haphazardly they still take it
upon themselves to communicate those
important things but they do it your
cell phones and I don't I mean it's not
because it's still largely illiterate
it's still I don't think that
immediately they're gonna lose their
because they're tremendously proud of
their culture and I don't and and so few
nomads have have emigrated out of their
country because they love their country
mono Dayak told me he was killed by the
way two weeks after I left him but he
told me a nomad always returns to his
first camp and he's been all over the
world but he came back and he snuck into
the desert to lead the rebellion because
he couldn't come in and publicly so they
are Wed to their desert and their
pasture land and their herding lifestyle
and even though some of them live in
cities and some of them are gone to
college I have our solar engineer that
does all our our solar work at the our
Center went to college in France but he
installs solar systems for nomadic
families in every summer he comes back
and spends his vacation with his nomadic
family all they live in the symbiote
symbiotic relationship with the people
that that move that live in the city and
sometimes the city people are doing
better than the nomads and sometimes the
nomads are doing better than the city
people and they just but they really
cherish their traditions and that I
don't think is is going to go away right
away it's still around
and I believe that when we're ready to
with you I'm probably not gonna last
forever like that's so I'm gonna keep
doing this as long as I can but I want
to be ready to turn over to them and and
let them continue with what they've
always done have a little bit more
better health care have a little more
opportunities the kids who are being
educated in the school they're going to
come back and be the director of the
clinic and the director of the school
one of these days they don't want to
leave they want to work where they where
they have always lived yeah the other
things that were coming through meter
you know time words that by doing
something like having a big database of
all the voice to voice communications
that they're now doing is a way to
preserve the language over time and that
that's the versus having if if there's
certain indigenous tribes disappear from
the face of the earth and all of the
culture is gone with them it's so hard
to go back and try and do any sort of
archaeology to identify that right so to
actually at least have a record of human
beings existing the way that they
communicated all this type of stuff yeah
it's a bunch of important projects going
on like the Rosetta project would go
long now foundation things like that
that are at least trying to preserve the
languages that have been spoken across
the planet things like that are
important and it's good that like you
said that that there's a increase in
general health that prevents mortality
that these types of things a of that can
get children to to come back and be the
director of the school or the clinic
afterward that type of stuff interesting
there's a lot of nuance still to
understand about the way that we can
take some of the indigenous wisdoms and
really embody them in this exponential
technology age that were
were bracing towards and also the way
that we can most effectively have links
like you were this link that made it
easier for us to that you took a lot of
big sacrifices leaps of faith in order
to become this link that then made it
easier to to provide the general health
and Economic Opportunity increases so to
figure out that it's gonna be it's gonna
be interesting in the next couple of
decades I want to see if there were so
many cool stories that you taught us
about the long journey and that was
still just like a tiny bit of the cool
stories what wait for my book wait for
the book yet so that'll be another
episode Leslie will hopefully 2020
next year hopefully is that she'll be
traveling painting writing that's the
plan now this was the beautiful last day
actually in the gallery after 23 years
in Ojai of bringing all the beautiful
paintings from around the world that you
ended up illustrating for for people to
bring into their homes and so okay does
it feel like we did a good job covering
the first piece of the conversation I
feel like we did really well I think we
did I think we do really want Leslie
we're so so cool I want to ask you just
um let's do two quick questions on the
way out the first question that was a
little bit out of left field but do you
think we're in a simulation what do you
mean like do you think that reality is a
simulation who knows I mean everybody's
reality is different and the one thing
that I've learned about when I step into
nomadic life and those the people I've
learned to never think I know anything
yes just experience it and don't impose
what I think
oh yes mark yes the show SH in the
beginners mindset the humility carrying
that with you at all times
yeah especially to to be able to learn
from people around the world yes yes and
okay the last question is what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world the most beautiful thing in the
world is its beauty I mean what it's
like
I can't there are so many things that
are beautiful and the only thing to me
that and the end the king is beauty
itself you you have to for me I I have
been accused or not accused but people
say oh you must be so observant because
I paint a lot and I can paint from life
from from what I see I am NOT I am
focused I extract the beautiful from
what I see and that it doesn't matter
what it is it is it is the essence of
something that just fills my heart and I
that's what I wanted to picked I've
taken friends into Tunisia and and we're
sitting watching this beautiful chair
awhile and they're going you smell that
dead donkey I didn't notice the dead
donkey you know it's it's I focus on
what I and I choose to make things
beautiful that's my my
and choice in life and I and I won't say
there's any one thing that's the most
beautiful thing in the world because
everything is if you make it self
yes that's a very valuable very valuable
takeaway that we can add Beauty to to
all of our different life experiences
and have our perception be geared in a
way that enables us to see that that
beauty and I love how you said that you
take this the essence of what's going on
in that moment and then that you find
the beating that and you bring it onto a
canvas and that that's your you bring it
other people from the share with them
Leslie thank you so much for talking to
us on the show for coming on thank you
thank you thank you so cool I'm so
excited to tell you another show on the
book when that's done everyone thank you
so much for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode let us know what you think about
about indigenous wisdom about nomadic
tribes about bringing general health
also bringing economic opportunity
please let us know your thoughts and
comments below also do check out the
links in the bio below as well nomads
gaol calm as well as no mountain no mad
foundation org check those out and go
and support the artists entrepreneurs
the the different spiritual leaders the
organizations in your communities around
with the world that you believe and
support them support simulation support
our show suing continue doing cool
things like coming on site to beautiful
place like Ojai and talking to awesome
people like Leslie and also go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace
that's a wrap that's around that was so
fun that was so fun